[Musique]
on est avant de reconnaître au porteur
on a tous descendus nos sacs qui vont
partir du coup
je pense qu'on va leur donner leurs
notes donation avec le cas oui
et leurs tee shirts formation va
apprendre à se connaître parce que simon
aura sûrement oublié des trucs dans
notre sac puis même si simple notre
gardien c'est lui qui accueille toutes
nos affaires quoi donc forcément il
[Musique]
rama stadium
beaucoup de gens
des changes
en montagne la neige
[Musique]
il
on attendait avec juste de plus rudes
niveau des conditions météo indique des
conditions en parle la température en
fait mais finalement ça allait
[Musique]
des petites ampoules deux élèves qui ont
eu mal au quai on leur a mis une petite
peau artificielle une deuxième peau et
au sabre et adrien
van zyl des montagnes c'est très souvent
quand on a été trop vite remonté trop
vite ton bien s'acclimater il faudra
montrer de 400 m par jour on peut monter
plus haut c'est ce qu'on va faire mais
on redescend pour dormir à la même
altitude
ça y est c'est vrai
que j'ai les moyens
c'est magnifique jamais vu un truc aussi
beau là on regarde on voit la forêt de
l'autre côté on voit la neige juste en
bail à la rivière les drapeaux
tricolores le ciel c'est magnifique
l'impression d'être un peu plus fatigué
que d'habitude je pense que c'est la
fatigue qui s'est accumulée mais sinon
c'était gelé quand même bien vécu
ça reste est supportable
[Musique]
j'ai eu beaucoup de plus de fatigue mal
au corps hélas la photo je me repose si
tout va
mabhouh beaux paysages pas c'était
naturel et beaucoup d'autres
[Musique]
on a un peu suivi la cascade on est
monté en altic fin la rivière on est
monté en altitude on est descendu mais
on est toujours resté près de près de
l'eau on a vu on a vu quelques singes
pour un premier jour ça va franchement
je suis fier de moi parce que c'est dur
quand même les montées elle chauffer un
peu les gens mais ça va c'était pas non
plus impossible et on est content
d'arriver
[Musique]
puis 6